[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
strange twitter messages from a defense
attorney in the cases against laurie
vallo
and her husband chad day bell accused in
the deaths of her children
prosecutors again pushed for the death
penalty against scott peterson
in an 18 year old saga suddenly upended
by appellate court rulings
and the ex-wife of the singer phil
collins suggests
he's spying on her with hidden cameras
plus a former nfl player is sentenced
after a rape conviction law on crime
daily covers court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin as always
prosecutors handling the case against
scott peterson will seek the death
penalty
yet again that information came out of a
court hearing for the convicted killer
whose case is getting a second look
thanks to appeals court victories
a jury convicted peterson of killing his
pregnant wife lacy
nearly two decades ago at a minimum a
new penalty phase is necessary the
appeals court ruled
but it's also possible an entirely new
trial will be held because of issues
with a juror
the judge refused all requests to
rebroadcast the hearing but here's what
happened
most of the hearing involved arguments
about procedure the defense argued that
it was the prosecutor's job to
decide a date for a new trial and the
defense demanded to know
whether the prosecutor was aiming for
the death penalty again and as we said
the answer was yes
the defense wanted that in writing and
asked for more time to speak with scott
peterson as a client
the next hearing in the case is november
6th the prosecutor estimated it might
take
six months to pick a jury because of the
coronavirus
pandemic one of peterson's attorneys
from his first trial told me that he
does deserve a new trial
it is reasonable it's reasonable to
expect fairness in our system we've got
one of the best systems in the world
and scott never got that fair trial and
he
he deserves another shot at it why not
and
is it reasonable to think that a jury
can acquit him of course
this was a circumstantial evidence the
prosecution couldn't even couldn't even
prove
how this happened where it happened when
it happened
there was no forensic evidence
connecting him to it the whole the
entire thing was based on a lot of
hatred people hated scott
and a lot of it had to do with the
cheating and some of the stuff he'd said
but that's not enough
former homicide prosecutor bernard
villalona tells law and crime that
retrying a case more than 15 years after
the original case
could cause issues for both the defense
and the state
you're dealing with witnesses that have
testified that now
don't have the same memory that they had
years ago so even though they can use
their transcripts to refresh their
recollection
it's not going to have the same effect
or the same
performance that those witnesses had
when they testified
during the trial so it's going to be
devastating on all
ends i really hope that it doesn't end
up that a new trial is going to happen
but one thing that the prosecutor may
consider in order to avoid a new trial
and putting these witnesses through this
and the family through this
is consider offering a plea to mr
peterson
to avoid a new trial in general attorney
imran ansari joins especially right now
along with terry and brian so brian
let's start with you right now
explain the defense concern over timing
and whose job it was to do what step of
the process that was a big part of the
discussion
there seemed to be some confusion over
what the law required in a situation
such as this where an appeals court
orders a new penalty phase and a
re-examination of an entire trial
yes there's a lot of moving pieces and
luckily for a defense attorney
a lot of those pieces don't have
anything to do with us in terms of
setting up
when the appeal is whether or not the
process is going to go forward and how
that trial is going to
occur that's a lot to do with the
prosecutor and the judge for the defense
your focus is laser focused on the
rights of your clients
and defending them as best as possible
when and where this retrial or this
re-sentencing occurs
that's really up to the court and the
prosecutor when they bring their
witnesses and a lot of back and forth
about exactly who is representing
peterson and what stage we've got
proceedings in different counties
so terry did the prosecutor ultimately
make the right call in your opinion to
retry the penalty phase of the case and
if so
what does that mean for the bigger trial
as a whole it seems like they're getting
ready
to do the entire thing all over again in
case the judge orders them to do so is
that the right
tactic for the prosecutor i do think
that the prosecution made the right
decision when he decided to
retry the penalty phase this was an
egregious crime
and it seems that the prosecutor really
wants to try to make sure that they get
the death penalty again and if
as you ask the entire trial is
redone again i think the prosecution has
to make sure
they pick jurors because that was the
issue they have to make sure that the
jurors
are you know disclosing everything and
they have to make sure that they don't
improperly exclude a juror and so i
think that uh
it might get retried and if they do
retry it they're going to be very
careful in voidier
and if you're a prosecutor you have to
assume the judge is going to say yes you
have to get your case ready
imran you were on the team which
litigated the high-profile harvey
weinstein case
where pre-trial publicity was in your
view a problem for your client
so as to scott peterson is 18 years from
the date of the crime
enough time to wipe this case clean from
the memories of the people who live in
that area can there be a fair jury there
well aaron look what we're doing right
now we're talking about the scott
peterson trial right so
we're years down the line and now you
have this uh order from the judge to uh
which which overturned that sentencing
phase you have the uh penal of the
actual conviction now under review for
the same sort of
uh jury uh selection issues and look
we're talking about it right now in the
media so will it be uh
different this time around perhaps maybe
it's going to be
less media than originally you know
because we had the whole uh case really
come to a forefront back then
but look we're talking about it now i
think it's going to be in the news
reports and again
there's going to be an issue in terms of
getting a fair impartial jury but i
think the prosecution is going to be all
the more careful
they're not going to want to do this for
a third time exactly
good words imran and of course terry and
brian as well
protests in waukegan illinois over the
police shooting of a young boyfriend and
girlfriend who say
they were just simply sitting in a car
nineteen-year-old marcellus
cenet died his girlfriend to farah
williams
survived the police say the pair were
sitting in a so-called suspicious
occupied vehicle when it then fled the
scene
with williams apparently driving they
say the vehicle started to back up and
an officer opened fire
in fear of his safety according to
police immediate questions began to
swirl among onlookers who were stunned
that the incident
led to shots being fired the county
attorney is reviewing the shooting and
has said
charges will be filed if he determines
the shooting was
a crime and out of the police shooting
death of briana taylor brian buckmeyer
has an update there
brian yes aaron so a second grand juror
in the brianna taylor case has released
a statement
right on the heels of the comments by
another grand juror who said prosecutors
didn't allow
those sitting in the seats of the
judgment to consider indicting
any of the officers involved for
actually shooting and killing taylor
the police gunned taylor down while
executing a warrant
taylor's boyfriend thought they were
breaking into his place
and fired a warning shot the police shot
back and taylor was killed
juror number two says the grand jury was
only allowed to consider
the three wanton endangerment charges
against detective hankinson
no opportunity to consider anything else
was permitted
anonymous grand juror number two agrees
wholeheartedly
with the statement released on behalf of
anonymous grand juror number one
and is looking forward to continuing to
help set the record straight
and look now at two cases we're
following here at law and crime a
sentencing hearing in salt lake city
utah where a defendant has admitted to
murdering a college student
23 year old mackenzie lewick disappeared
after taking a lyft ride home from her
grandmother's funeral
ayula ajaye admitted to strangling lueck
at his house burning her body
and burying it in his backyard ajaye's
guilty plea
came with a promise by prosecutors not
to seek the death penalty
we'll have some of the hearing on a
future broadcast due to a court ordered
transmission delay
another case we're bringing you soon is
that a former minor league
ball player accused of using a baseball
bat of all things to beat his father his
uncle
and repair man to death inside a
california home
brandon willie martin faces three counts
of first degree murder
authorities say he committed the
killings right after he was released
from a mental health evaluation
prosecutors are going for the death
penalty in that case
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily new reports are shedding light on
alleged crimes against a 90s child
star also sentencing for a former
defense tackle for the san francisco
49ers
after a jury convicted him of rape
[Music]
welcome back everybody former san
francisco 49er dana stubblefield is
heading to prison for 15 years to life
for rape
a jury in santa clara county california
found stubblefield guilty of rape
and other charges last summer
prosecutors said stubblefield contacted
the 31 year old victim through a
babysitting website in 2015.
when she went to his home he used a gun
to assault her
prosecutor tim mcearney said this about
the sentence
no meant nothing to this defendant based
on his status i think he has never
been held accountable for prior criminal
behavior today
he was properly held accountable
mcgurney also added that the accuser
testified
with bravery poise and grace and allowed
the jury to get a true picture
of the man the judge in the case denied
a defense motion for a new trial
everybody's back now to discuss this
case briefly here so terry that
prosecutor statement is quite powerful
it summarizes why the jury made the
decision it did
yeah i agree you know when you have
someone who is in a
powerful position and they have control
and influence over someone
who is obviously less powerful i think
the jury's going to take that seriously
and we've seen
these types of cases before where
someone like this an
ex-football player is really penalized
because they
are trying to control the individual
and you know she testified she was on
the stand for a long time
other witnesses testified so i
definitely think that uh the jury
is thinking the right way here and
penalizing him for taking advantage of
his power
imran it's oftentimes very difficult for
a defense attorney to try to raise
reasonable doubt
against the victim's testimony in a case
like this can you take us through the
struggle
yeah well you're you're always going to
have a problem when you have sort of
salacious facts and egregious facts
before the jury
uh put on by the state like this case i
mean you have a
an nfl player who you know has this
appearance of a hulking
uh sort of uh physical appearance taking
advantage of someone with uh
disabilities and it's really how are you
going to do that well you're going to
have to poke
holes into the prosecution's case you're
going to have to point out all the areas
of reasonable doubt
in that case and hope that the jury even
though they're hearing all these
salacious facts and all these really
shocking
facts from the prosecution um is held to
the
holds the prosecution to the burden of
proving their case beyond a reasonable
doubt
and you're gonna have to do everything
in your power as a defense attorney to
poke holes in that case
so brian is the sentence fair as a
defense attorney is the sentence fair or
does the prosecutor's statement make you
think that he's being singled out the
defendant's being singled out
because of his status for a harsher
punishment i think
they are being punished a little bit too
hard that being dana stubblefield
take out the nfl aspect okay did the nf
the fact that he can run a ball faster
than
most of us or push more waste than most
of us had anything to do with this no
did he use his body or a weapon to to
perpetrate this crime
yes is he an anchor at a long crime
daily is he a public defender is he
harvey weinstein attorney
no that fact doesn't mean anything and
that shouldn't be used when it comes to
sentencing
so here you think the sentence was fair
i think the sentence could be fair but
if you're implementing the fact that
he's an nfl player to
up the ante on that sentencing i think
it has nothing to do with this crime and
it's improperly used
all right good opinions here from
everybody terry you've got a couple of
updates and other celebrity legal
matters for us
right aaron new possible details are
coming out about the alleged assault of
a home improvement star's
girlfriend tmz reports that zachary ty
brian pulled his girlfriend out of her
bed by her hair
and beat her while cursing about missing
cell phone charges
those reports cite police records but
the police refused to provide the
information to long crime
brian faces two felony charges of
strangulation
and coercion along with misdemeanor
charges he's out on bail
and can't have any contact with the
girlfriend
phil collins's ex-wife is firing back
through court documents
after the pop star asked a judge to
remove her from
his house in miami collins claims orion
collins bates and her new husband won't
leave the house
and even hired armed guards to help them
stay put
but bates says the armed security has
always been there
and collins knew it and that collins
chose to leave the home
suddenly she also claims she found
hidden
cameras in her bathroom and dressing
room and that
footage from security cameras was erased
after the family's dog died thanks a lot
for the update to those cases terry and
coming up here on law and crime daily at
courthouse so
dangerous a judge shuts down an entrance
and later on
defense attorneys in the cases involving
lori vallo and her husband chad dabell
are preparing a court fight over whether
the couple should be tried together or
separately we'll be back right after
[Music]
this
okay everybody now to an incident
involving a courthouse in the overnight
hours
involving a metal sign and pepper spray
here's dan abrams from a clip from court
cam which
airs on the a e network
we kicked things off at the king county
courthouse in seattle washington
recently described by a local politician
as the most
dangerous place in seattle
it's about 4 am and things look quiet
outside the courthouse
but then this man jacob jackson
approaches a locked entrance
he forces his way inside
right away the trouble begins
nearby a guard hears the commotion
things escalate quickly as jackson says
unless you kill me i'll keep coming in
unarmed the guard goes for the nearest
weapon he can find
jackson's determined and continue
straight ahead
until backup arrives
armed with pepper spray
that does it jackson retreats and heads
for the exit
cops catch up to him down the street
where he's arrested and charged with
burglary
and just a month earlier cameras caught
a much more violent incident
this time just outside the king county
courthouse
that's frank hippolyte
and that's attorney kevin mccabe being
pummeled by hippolyte
in a completely unprovoked attack and in
broad daylight
the attorney's shaken but the attack
seems to be over
a bus driver gets out of his bus and
appears to snap a photo of hippolyte
in a rage hippolyte sends both men to
the ground
before a court marshal arrives with a
taser
the jolt of electricity drops hippolyte
to the pavement
he's then arrested and charged with
assault
since january 2019 police have responded
to over 160 assaults outside this
courthouse
things are so bad a judge ordered the
third avenue entrance
temporarily closed until things improve
and when we come back tweets involving
rats of all things in the cases against
lori valo and her husband chad dabal
the pair are accused of conspiring to
hide her children's remains
[Music]
the unusual case of a so-called doomsday
cult mother and her husband charged in
the deaths of her two children seems to
be getting a bit
more unusual lori valo and chad dabel
are accused of conspiring to alter
conceal or destroy evidence
the bodies of valo's two children jj and
tyler ryan
were found buried in daebel's backyard
prosecutors want to try the two
together and a hearing to decide that
request is scheduled for next week
dabel's attorney is objecting velo's
attorney mark means says he's not
objecting however he took to twitter to
post his theory
on the case as i prepare the defense for
lori valodebel i am
learning that persons like melanie gibb
and her boyfriend david warwick
appear to have been eagerly involved
in more than they let on if you know
something
say something and look at the picture
melanie gibb and david warwick are key
witnesses for the state remember
gibb was velo's best friend but created
a secret recording of the defendant and
gave it to the police
at a pre-trial hearing means said gibb
might have an incentive to lie
at some point there was a question
regarding the whereabouts of
jj is that right correct and at that
point you had
advised him that you had had jj in your
care
correct i told him that i had him and
then i didn't have him
okay so the initial time that he told
him that you had jj that was not a
truthful statement
to officer piller was it correct and
when you tell a statement that's that's
not accurate
to a police officer that's that's a lie
is it not
correct so you lied to a police officer
is that correct
correct and then at some point how long
between the time
when you told that lie to the police
officer regarding the whereabouts of j.j
valo
did you correct your lie how much time
passed
till i spoke to him on december
6th i believe i could be off a day or
two
so approximately 10 to 12 days passed
from the time you told your first lie
to when you decided to come up with a
different story for officer gilbert
later on correct
correct all right let's go back to
twitter here terry
means went on to tweet the defense lacks
the resources of the prosecution state
of idaho attorney general of idaho fbi
chandler police madison county sheriff's
department fremont county sheriff's
department
rexburg police etc we need the persons
of knowledge to come
forward what is he getting at here terry
i have no idea what persons of knowledge
is he talking about i mean mark means is
doing his best to protect lori valo
but the fact is melanie gibb is a person
of knowledge and she's
already stated that you know lori asked
her to lie
she's already stated that you know lori
thinks that there are zombies going
around and people should be dying so i'm
not sure
what mark means is trying to get at here
i don't think there are any other people
out there
who are going to be defending lori valo
imran should this guy be tweeting this
way is this a good
public strategy for a defense attorney
to take
well aaron i think you know this is
really an indication of the social media
error
that we are in we are not seeing a
defense attorney using their
private investigator to go find
witnesses you have a
defense attorney going on twitter and
tweeting
looking for people who may have some
information to assist his clients
defense
and he uses a gif right that image of
the rats running what is that suggesting
is that suggesting that the state's
witnesses
are just a bunch of rats and and doing
something to uh help themselves
and is that unethical that those are
some sort of questions you know these
are questions that
you got to grapple with when you are an
attorney with an active case and you're
going on social media
and tweeting like this yeah a lot of
questions here brian i wish we could get
your thoughts on the rats but we're out
of time here we'll have to get it next
time or we'll talk after the show thanks
for joining us everybody here on long
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america probably no rats next
time though
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
so
[Music]
you